Nhật lệ bị phần em dưới công kích yêu cầu quang lình vi lúc xí lợi mình.
Nếu theo dõi quang lình vi lúc, thậm con lình xí ngọng những chiến thăm chỉ bây bài,
chắc khảnh sẽ biết anh chàng có chị gái là nhật lệ cũng là một kương hoạt đời tiểu ký sự vụ bệ trăm tảm lâm nghiên lực theo dõi.
Hãy em thường châu đô và các kẻ nhau trên mạc,
sống mới đây, nhật lệ lãn quang linh đã khả phải một tình cũng dự khắp sự gười khi chị gái công khai nó sấu em dô.
Thều đó, nhất lệ đã ngợi thẳng, cứ tế video của quang linh là điều nhất luôn vì không hệ thể em mình đẹp trai.
Chị thể mình đẹp nhất nha, của quang đời rằng sẽ cảm biết tích tốt của quang linh để phố lâu cả xíng lúc tùng xưa hôm sau,
anh chẳng sẽ biết đồ là quang linh công khai hệ nha.
Mới đây, nhất lệ đã phải linh tự xí lợi vì nhận phải của anh yêu bình lợi công việc sau khi con anh khả kệ quang linh,
tốt giải tích cả xí là một lời chêu đổi thôi.
Anh chỉ em trong nhà thì không mọi nhau đơn à, không kể nhau bao giờ à,
mới bạc đi tốt xíc, chắc gì đã tươi bằng mình. Nhà mình không phân cấp chêu đợi vị,
chêu đơn à lươi tự hơn thì đo đúng. Nên chỉ em trong nhà thoải mai lắm,
con anh cũng kể nữ khổ tâm khi quang linh các kệ mình thì không sao? Để khi bạn thân chổ lại quang linh
là bị phân xung vào công việc để plễ hơi kia xe. Khổ tâm là mọi người.
Hãy chỉ em ở gần nhau mà nó không xe mấy cây, có ai chừng hợp khi mình nhận tên một anh nó không xe khai là nó chỉ xe ím,
bây giờ lên mạc thì nghĩ vân có linh chữ, con anh tình mặc nó thì nó không xa lời.
Được biết, mất con hệ với con linh và lịch lệ với rất tốt, anh chẳng tình thọng vẫn đang hình với chị gái trên chẳng cây nhanh,
cho tệ cũng hỗ trợ công việc, và có mất con hệ thân thiết với nhiều người trong tìm cho phi.